I read the book Breath by James Nestor
every single chapter in that book talks
about how mouth breathing is like the
coming of Satan all of these negative
effects is mouth breathing like actually
killing us you look at the experiment he
did where he bunged his nose up with two
earplugs for ten days he looked really
bad at the end of those 10 days within
the first day or so his blood pressure
had gone up x amount of points his sleep
was impacted and then I think he said
you know something like 30 the American
population are breathing like this all
the time when he took those earplugs out
of his nose within a matter of hours his
blood pressure started to come back down
again and started to feel more himself